we've driven just a few hours outside
karachi pakistan's main financial hub
and largest city and already we are
seeing water as far
as the eye can see those trees
completely submerged right up the trunk
to the leaves and some of the smaller
trees actually look like bushes as we're
driving down now this is not a river
that's burst its bank this is rainfall
in what pakistan is terming a monster
monsoon in some parts they've seen up to
five or six times the average tipping
down up and down the country
than they would normally see in a year
and and look at this ground there's been
a heat wave too it is scorched and
scarred and incredibly dry
i've got to tell you it's really hot
already today it was expected to hit 40
degrees it has hit 53 degrees in this
province which is called sindh now
that heat wave culminating with the
unprecedented monsoon it's come earlier
it's come faster it's come heavier the
heat is actually melting pakistan's
glaciers it's home to some seven
thousand glaciers they're creating lakes
that are overflowing
and that water is expected to rush down
the country to here at some point later
creating more chaos and it's making
people and forcing them to leave their
homes if you take a look at this this is
an entire
village that have been forced up onto
the banks here
presumably their homes were down here at
some point and and while i've been
talking to you like i've just spotted i
don't know if um my cameraman nasa can
zoom in and show you there's two
children in this water
they're bringing what looks like trees
and branches
up onto the bank presumably to create
more makeshift homes there are children
swimming in this water and this is not
clean
drinking water this is water mixed with
sewage there's a concern of course now
and there will be in the coming months
and presumably up to a year to come of
waterborne diseases
um this community does have a couple of
boats we've just seen one leaving
there's another boat there and they're
using that to get what little ladies
arriving from the main road
to
their their small makeshift community
here
now pakistan has held a press conference
today saying that they are stretched
their capacity
and their resources and they are calling
for international help for what they are
terming the ground zero of climate-led
change in the world